what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us trying to get our lunch money
right
i'm here with paulina she looks
amazingly
it's happy international women's day
she's very happy today all right
so don't forget that block five is now
the sponsor of lunch money you can go to
blockbuy.com
where you can earn up to eight point six
percent apy in an interest bearing
account you can take out a us dollar
load
against your crypto collateral or you
can buy and sell
crypto on their crypto exchange you
thought i forgot i didn't they're coming
off my credit card go get your credit
card i need to get my monday energy up
in this place let's go blockfy.com pomp
so own norway listed company
acre is that how you say it has set up a
new company dedicated to investing in
bitcoin projects and companies
in an announcement monday the holding
company focused on energy construction
and fishing
said its new entity ct will keep
all of its liquid investable assets in
bitcoin and will also enter the bitcoin
mining industry
why is a company that's focused on
energy construction and fishing doing
this
because the billionaire is
forward-thinking you don't become a
billionaire but being an idiot
everybody knows that billionaires are
not stupid billionaires are rich because
billionaires figured out how to make
money
and what he obviously understands is
that bitcoin is going to be part of the
future
he believes that there is going to be a
new financial system some of the old
players will participate new systems
some of the new players will
disrupt the old players and so he wants
to be a part of that and so he's
participating
i am in contact with them i will come
back to you once i learn more
interesting jp morgan sent its private
clients a primer on
crypto it's been distributed to clients
of uh jpmorgan private bank which
requires
a minimum balance of 10 million dollars
to open an account
and it basically uh educated them on the
risks and opportunities of investing in
crypto
now do you think that jp morgan's doing
that because they're getting all these
questions from their clients about
crypto
i think one they're getting tons of
questions two i think that they
generally are interested in this stuff
three they want to be seen as a thought
leader is educational
uh and four is if their clients are
going to do this
and they can establish themselves as
that thought leader then
obviously they're going to end up
building product services that
incorporate uh crypto with their clients
no-brainer duh
every bank's doing it shouldn't even be
news anymore
starling bank a digital only challenger
bank in the uk
has raised 376 million dollars in an
investment round
led by fidelity investments which values
starling at 1.5 billion dollars
wow these challenger banks what do we
think yeah i mean
everyone's gonna have to be a bank
whether you are a
uh company that is just a technology
company and then you slowly start to
move closer and closer to the
the wallet share into money or if you
are already in the financial industry
and you just become more vertically
integrated
everyone has to become a bank or as
close to it as possible over time
and i think that's what you're seeing
here it's very interesting that fidelity
who's a legacy incumbent player
is participating in funding this uh
because again fidelity's just proven
time and again to be one of the most
forward-thinking
uh investment institutions uh on wall
street and it's all because abby johnson
who is the ceo
uh she gets it and she is all over the
digital transformation of uh you're
talking about ceo fidelity
yes the ceo of starling her name is ann
bowden it says digital banking has
reached a tipping point
customers now expect a fairer smarter
and more human alternative to the banks
of the past and that is where we
and that is what we're giving them at
sterling as we continue to grow and add
new products and services
duh cool next philanthropist
mackenzie scott ex-wife of jeff bezos
has married a seattle school teacher
and if that wasn't enough the biggest
flex of
dan joette um a science teacher at a
private school
he also signed the giving pledge
pledging to give
the majority of his wealth out and away
throughout his life he had a fire quote
he said
it is strange to be writing a letter
indicated indicating i plan to give away
the majority of my wealth during my
lifetime
is i have never sought to gather the
kind of wealth required to feel like
saying such a thing
would have particular meaning they also
got jeff bezos uh given a quote on dan
he said dan is such a great guy and i'm
happy and excited for the both of them
i don't know what i think about this yet
i like it
are you kidding me i feel like this is
the type
of story that gets presented in a very
positive light
well because literally the headline is
all about
she marries the school teacher and like
it's like this amazing thing
but at the same time it feels weird that
everyone was going after jeff bezos
saying
hey this guy's a scumbag look what he's
doing whatever and she's now getting
married to somebody else
just the whole thing is feels like you
know
the coverage is very one-sided it's like
she's amazing
he's not i think the truth is probably
somewhere in between so here's what i
appreciate about mackenzie scott she
does not do
interviews with the press i don't think
she's ever done a
uh profile where she's talked to the
press um
but she puts her money where her mouth
is she based on her actions you can see
where her values lie and she doesn't
have to speak to anybody to prove that
all that is fair but 18 months after she
got divorced
she now got married jeff bezos has not
been married well i'm just i'm just
saying
yeah jeff bezos had a mistress again
again i'm saying that the truth is
somewhere in between i just think that
uh it seems like coverage of this
situation
is very very different like we could say
i disagree your dad's calling you he's
trying to yell at you your dad's calling
you trying to yell at you i disagree
because we all remember
the spectacle that could have been jeff
bezos's
um nude picture inappropriate pictures
he sent
his mistress and the coverage was
quite positive i will i must say i'm
just saying
okay that let's move on paulina's not
happy with that uh jack
dorsey is offering to sell the first
tweet as an nft
and the highest bid is 2.5 million
dollars
what do you think tweet i don't quite
who's the bitter i saw two
two million was justin's son what
justin's son had bid
two million oh justin i heard john cena
estavia bridge oracle
uh 2.5 million yeah we'll see what
happens um
i think that jack is not going to accept
the money i think he's going to donate
it
or or he'll accept and he'll donate it
yeah like i like he's not doing this to
make money
um so it'll be very interesting to see
what the final price is
but it does begin to question ownership
does that mean that twitter no longer
owns that tweet because somebody's
bought it
right like technically right now it's
twitter's tweet it's
their content twitter owns that tweet
i don't know but if jack sells it who
owns the intellectual world
that'll have to we'll have to learn soon
all right ready yes let's do it moist
counter
okay guys so first of all never in my
29 years on earth am i 29. god you're
such a child
and not not a single time in my 29 years
on earth did i ever think that i would
be reading about a moist
battle but um you know how there's moist
then wet got in the comments now there's
somebody named soggy
and soggy goes day number one moist and
wet or cool but not as cool as soggy
hashtag moist fork and then
somebody said who's gonna show up next
damp
uh and then wet commented and said alexa
google soggy alexa says wet and soft
dawn lifeless nah saggy got nothing on
that oh gee
hashtag moist hard fork hashtag feeling
hey this is getting out feeling wet
taking out that soggy garbage and then
sage responded with
be wet get rekt listen i don't know
what's going on in the comments on
youtube but i got wet soggy and moist
all arguing with each other moist we're
gonna move
wet and soggy to the side they are uh
imitators at the moment i'm very
entertained by it please continue
but i'm impressed voiced my questions
first of all it's hashtag asklm i didn't
see any good questions in the comments
do better be better okay
uh don't read this one i i don't want to
i don't want to give this
moist says day 17 of commenting on every
episode of lunch money until pomp gives
me a call
i am in fact a genius thank you for the
endorsement i live in the mountains so
when i take a girl on a first date it
involves either a nature hike
or driving to a scenic overlook then
getting food after of course the quality
of the restaurant depends on the quality
of the girl
oh jesus christ hashtag
unleash the moisture what is your next
question for moist
are you bringing her home on the first
night or
are you more of a let's go on a couple
of dates first what what is the angle
i'm gonna shut this down
as you go on the day you go to the
mountains you go to get a little hiking
you know sweat a little bit
go either mcdonald's or like a ruth
chris steakhouse
you know either end of the spectrum and
then and then
what is the angle is it uh i'll drop you
off at your door nice to see you maybe
we'll go on another date
or is it uh you should see my apartment
i've got some really cool stuff that uh
you should come see
if i took you on a hike you would
literally pass out from not being able
to breathe so
let's let's if the quality of the
questions do not
go up i am shutting down moist i am
shutting it down you ain't shut down
i got a whole gang it's me moist wet and
soggy and we coming for everything
all right pomp moist wet and soggy are
coming for everything
i know that they're [ __ ] cool damp i
know you're on my side damp where are
you at
damp isn't in existence damn pulling
which means you got no friends it means
you got no friends see ya
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan what
you're a bigger fan of block five than
you are of me block flies my second
favorite thing in the world behind
paulina
they've got three products they can give
you a us dollar loan
you can earn up to eight point six
percent interest on an interest bearing
account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends